this is phase four thank you now there's
a lot other stuff we didn't get a chance
to talk about today we even mentioned it
would make it black panther - we didn't
mention the fact that guardians galaxy 3
is coming you have time to talk about
Captain Marvel - I didn't even have time
to talk about the Fantastic Four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about a
mutant
[Applause]
but all that smells good rumor and
you've heard about rumors
although the phase five lineup was
teased at San Diego comic-con in
Marvel's Hall H panel we really don't
know much about it although today it
does seem like some of the movies have
been revealed with the release dates for
them as well how's it going everybody
it's Warren
and phase five is coming sooner than you
think you may have noticed that phase
four is only two years long that's a
little shorter than all of the phases
that we've gotten in the past but it
really doesn't matter because as soon as
phase four ends we're going to jump
right into phase five if you look at the
phase four lineup you can notice that
the last film of phase 4 Thor love and
thunder is going to be released on
November 5th 2021 so phase 4 only goes
from May 1st 2020 to November 5th 2021
but as I mentioned it seems like part of
phase 5 was revealed and we do have some
dates to go along with some of the
beginning movies of phase 5 so I'll
break it all down in this video quick
reminder if you'd like a chance to win
in xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain I'll be picking a
winner at 500,000 subscribers so this
update on phase 5 today comes from
Charles Murphy and Charles has revealed
things in the past about the MCU that
have been very accurate his most recent
one being the shang-chi casting which he
was 100% correct about and he recently
sent out this tweet about phase 5 always
subject to change and still much we
don't know
phase 5 be to February 18th 2022 black
panther 2 may 6 2012 the galaxy vol 3
July 29th 2022 blank may 3rd or 10th
2024 and then he put a shocked face
after so according to this report we
have black panther 2 and guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 kicking off phase 5 of
the MCU
we didn't mention the fact that
guardians galaxy 3 is coming and these
make perfect sense because Black Panther
was such a huge success and black
panther moving forward is going to be a
big part of the MCU and the Avengers
team and there have been plenty of
reports and leaks about Black Panther 2
so it would make sense that it would be
coming in the beginning of phase 5 and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 being the
second slot of phase 5 makes perfect
sense as well James Gunn is back to
direct guardians of the galaxy vol 3 but
we know that he has to finish up the
Suicide Squad to first he has even
commented and confirmed this himself
that he has to finish Suicide Squad
before he can focus on guardians of the
galaxy volume 3 but Suicide Squad is
scheduled for release in 2021 so that
gives him plenty of time to work on
guardians volume 3 and we know that the
script is done he has had the script for
guardians 3 done for a very long time
now the July 29th 2022 slot is a bit of
a mystery right now it could be Captain
Marvel 2 or it could be the new blade
movie coming out however we do know that
the may 3rd or 10th 2024 slot is most
likely a heroes team-up film now this
could be the Avengers or it could be a
completely different team up film we
have the Fantastic Four coming into the
MCU we have the x-men coming there could
be a Young Avengers there could also be
an a force so there are a lot of
possibilities but at the same time Kevin
Feige has confirmed that there will be a
new Avengers team in an interview right
after the reveal of phase 4 Kevin Feige
was asked if there's going to be a new
Avengers team and if he knows what that
looks like in which he confirmed yes
there is going to be a new Avengers team
and it is going to be very different
than anything that we've seen before so
this slot could very well be a new
Avengers movie luckily for us we are
expected to learn more about phase 5
pretty soon we could even possibly learn
a little bit more about it at Disney's
d23 event that is happening this month
so let me know what you think about
black panther 2 and guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 kicking off phase 5 of the
MCU also let me know what you think
about the next team up movie what you
think it could be and what do you think
that mystery movie is be sure to let me
know all your thoughts in the comments
down below also don't forget to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU also don't forget to follow
me on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof